is it possible to get into MVB with an
extremely low GPA and I have 3 years of
experience so let's just say it will be
extremely difficult especially if your
GPA is really low so I'd say if your GPA
maybe is average but not super Stellar
then it already will be tough but
probably you can compensate that if some
other parts of your profile are really
Stellar but if your GPA is really low
then again I don't want to say it's
impossible maybe if you're really a
genius a superstar and this comes true
through your application by other areas
of your profile then maybe you have a
shot but for most people I consider it
really difficult